so I'm pleased to Jeremy con last
Speaker of the day is going to talk
about everything
so let's see here yeah so Freeman Dyson
Freeman Dyson said that there are two
kinds of mathematicians well there are
those who can draw in those who can't
draw and you'll see very rapidly which
ones there are which one I am so there
are this looks more like an airplane but
it's supposed to be a bird oh oh there
we go sorry it's too bright huh it's too
bright let's bring it down so they're
they're birds and they're they're birds
that look more like airplanes and then
there are these creatures that aren't
really going to look anything like what
I wanted to look like but there are two
these um frocks this is bi told you to
be better than the Mandelbrot set oh and
that the birds fly in the air and the
frogs jump along the ground and the
birds see a very birdeye view of course
in the Frog see just a little bit of
ground right in front of them and I
spent most of my life as a frog and I'm
kind of happy to be a frog but for this
plenary talk at the office bears
colloquium which I kind of always wanted
to give I'm going to try to be a bird
and give a kind of bird's eye view of
some mathematics and I hope that the
lecture will be better than the
illustrations so the main results here
and its broadest form is a theorem about
three manifolds and it says that if we
have a closed and a spherical three
manifold by a spherical I just mean
really no higher houma topi groups then
M has a finite cover which has with an
essential embedded two-sided surface
okay and for this purposes of this I'll
just say you know not a sphere but some
hi Regina surface and another way of
saying it is that M is virtually hakan
so let me just um introduce basic
terminology in case you haven't seen it
and virtually has some property if a
finite cover of em has a property mm is
a group gamma virtually has a property
if a finite index sub group has that
property because of course if you take a
finite cover of a manifold you're taking
a finite index subgroup of its
fundamental group will say a surface or
more generally a manifold but for our
purpose is a surface that's embedded or
immersed in a a manifold is essential
for example a service immersed in two or
three manifold is essential if it's
injective on fundamental group and
finally we'll say m is hakan if it has
an essential embedded two-sided surface
so by two-sided I just mean the normal
bundle is orientable okay that's our
basic terminology so the virtual hakan
theorem just says that if m is closed in
a spherical then closed in a spherical
three manifold then m is virtually hakan
and this goes back i believed to Wald
housing and it's a theorem in geometric
topology it's it stated just the kind of
purely topological statement and we're
going to use practically everything but
topology and are to prove this theorem
we're going to use to metro's a shin and
hyperbolic geometry and cube complexes
okay so that's what this lecture is
about all right and I am priest let's
see here i am pleased to announce the
return a virtual hakan man virtual hakan
man whisperer
seen in princeton in the spring of 2012
and then his head appeared on Ian angles
a facebook page and now he is returned
than his full glory with a cup of coffee
so the virtual hakan man is we'll see is
built on the foundation of thurston
perelman geometric Nets the ground that
he walks on and the virtual hockey man
which is really the virtual hakan
theorem for closed hyperbolic three
manifolds well his pants of course is
his legs are my work with Vladimir
Markovich on the service subgroup
theorem and and his waist his belt so to
speak is provided by the burger on wise
cumulation after the work of me guess I
gave and his chest is the work of Danny
wise the MAL normal special quotient
theorem and i should add QC h employs
for a truly special I guess QC h and
hyperbolic implies virtually special and
and also his arms are the tagging why
sort of idea of special cube complexes
and accumulation and the combination
theorem of hey Gwen and was and then his
neck is the Agel gross Manning week
separable atithi Rimmel normal special
quotient theorem and finally his head
which is a sort of the latest and
greatest result is angles virtual
special theorem for a word hyperbolic
cumulated groups
okay so that's virtual hakan theorem
he's gotten himself a cup of coffee and
he sat down to watch the rest of the
lecture so you see how I do so first
regretting rotating okay so first again
the ground that virtual hakan man walks
on is Thurston Pelham and geo metros a
shin so this is a theorem about kind of
an arbitrary closed three manifold at
first we can decompose it in an entirely
canonical way by connected some and then
we can cut the pieces that are
irreducible along essential embedded
torah and again that's essentially
canonical and then we get pieces which
have geometric structures ok and that's
well a kind of brief statement i should
say what a geometric structure is that's
kind of brief statement of their sin
perlman geo metros a shin it was
conjectured by Thurston and proven by
Chris Chappell men using the Ricci flow
based on ideas i should add of richard
hamilton all right so briefly what does
this mean a geometric structure on a
three manifold or really on any manifold
is a Romani and metric on M such that
the universal cover is a homogeneous
space ok so it's a kind of nice very
locally homogeneous Romani and metric
and i should add if m is not compact we
want that with this romania metric m has
finite volume and we can classify the
geometric structures that it can appear
on three manifolds by their Universal
covers and we see that they're actually
just eight of them up to sort of obvious
forms of rescaling and for seven out of
eight there are simple topological
models for what the three manifold is up
to finite cover ok so let me show you I
should slow down just a second so you
can read none all right let me show you
let me show you what these eight
geometries are I'm not going to define
them because well exception of
hyperbolic they're kind of defined
almost by what these finite covers look
like so the first possibility is that
the universal cover is s3 with a
spherical metric and then because s3 is
compact any quotient of it has a finite
cover which is s3 so that's rather
simple and almost as simple we could
have s to cross the real line and then M
has a finite cover practically M is s to
cross s1 or we could have em have
Euclidean geometry and then M has a
finite cover which is a 3 Taurus m can
be the hyperbolic plane cross R and then
M has a finite cover which is a higher
service of genus greater than 1 a
hyperbolic surface cross the unit circle
or M could have the geometry basically
you take the unit tangent bundle of two
dimensional hyperbolic space and that
has fundamental group Z so you take the
universal cover of that that's simply
connected and in this case well if you
took for example the unit tangent bundle
of a compact surface that of course
would have that kind of geometry and in
general em has a finite cover which is
some non-trivial circle bundle over a
surface so that's relatively easy to
classify they're classified by their
euler class and there are certain rules
about what it can be and we can continue
there's this thing called Neil geometry
and usually people think of it as coming
from a twisted circle bundle over a
torus i actually prefer to think of it
as if you take a tourist bundle so just
a to tourists bundle over a circle with
non-trivial parabolic monodromy so if
you had periodic monitoring that would
give you a Euclidean geometry but if you
have parabolic monitoring that gives you
an ill geometry so there's a neat
theorem
I've never seen anywhere that if you
have any tourist bundle over a circle it
has a geometric structure because you
can always think of the monodromy you
can always interpolate sort of smoothly
by the exponential map from the identity
to the matrix that gives you the
monitoring and that implies that any
tourist bundle over the circle has a
homogeneous structure so this almost
defines what mill geometry is you just
construct that um that geometric
structure and then likewise if we have a
tourist bundle over s one with
hyperbolic mono drumming so one
eigenvalue greater than one when i can
value less than one for the two by two
matrix that determines the monodromy
then the geometry that you get is solved
geometry and anything we solve geometry
is virtually such an object and then
finally the eighth geometry and the one
that we're going to be studying for the
rest of this lecture is hyperbolic
geometry and I should probably say a
word or two of what that is but and in
hyperbolic geometry there's a very deep
theorem which is pretty much the object
of this lecture and is very closely
related to the virtual hakan theorem for
hyperbolic three manifolds and this very
deep theorem says that if m i mean
there's already a very deep theorem of
thurston that says if you have a surface
of higher genus genus greater than one
that has pseudo a NOSSA of mono Germans
so it's kind of stretched along a
foliation with singularities in one
direction and contracted along a
foliation in the opposite direction kind
of analogous to a hyperbolic map on a
torus so if you have such a bundle with
pseudo and also of mono drumming then
that has a hyperbolic structure that's
already a deep theorem of Thurston and
I'd say it's an equally deep theorem
that I will be explaining in this
lecture that the kind of converse holds
that if you have a closed hyperbolic
three manifold then virtually it's
exactly such a fiber three men
old okay and so for the first seven of
these this is relatively elementary and
then for the eighth understanding
hyperbolic geometry it's a kind of very
deep theorem okay so does everyone know
what hyperbolic geometry is let me just
say a word of it you have like for
example h2 we could think of it as
sitting in our two and the metric is
something like DX squared plus dy
squared over Y squared and the gd6 look
like semi circles orthogonal to the real
line or straight lines going up and then
if i add if I make this DZ squared over
Z squared yeah it should be over C
squared and I've gotten h3 in r3 and the
point is it's the unique isotropic
geometry so it looks not only the same
everywhere but every frame is the same
as every other frame in which kind of
lines curve away from each other so if
you have two typical non intersecting
lines say in the plane they start out
far away they come close and then they
go far away again all right i'm hoping
that most of you know hyperbolic
geometry okay so then our main theorem
here which I'm going to attribute I mean
Ian a goal proved the last step of it
but I'm going to tribute this theorem
for the sake of this lecture to virtual
hakan man of which eagles work is the
head and it says if you have a closed
hyperbolic three manifold then it's
virtually hakan so I said a moment ago
it's also virtually fibered of course if
you have a fiber three manifold that has
this essential of our surface which is
the fiber so virtually fiber is stronger
than virtually hakan but the real work
in a way it's proving virtually hakan
and then we'll see that implies
virtually fiber and then a corollary of
this theorem is sort of easy corollary
is if m3
and if you have any clothes a spherical
three manifold then M is virtually hakan
because well because it's a spherical
it's irreducible if you can cut it along
a torus then of course it's Hawking and
otherwise it has a geometric structure
and in the other seven out of eight
cases we saw its relatively elementary
so that leaves only the case where m is
a closed hyperbolic three manifold ok so
our remaining work in this lecture is to
prove the theorem of virtual hakan man
ok so it begins with my work with
Vladimir markovich which says we start
with our clothes hyperbolic three
manifold m and we can find a map of a
surface a hyperbolic surface into m and
this map will be PI 1 injective it will
not be an embedding but it will be
injective on fundamental group and
moreover it will be kind of nearly
isometric and nearly geodesic so if we
add and we can say more than that
because i want to say service subgroups
or everywhere so we can pass if we lift
to the universal cover so we get a map
from two-dimensional hyperbolic space
into three-dimensional hyperbolic space
and I'm saying we can make this as close
as we want to an arbitrary geodesic
plane if I choose an arbitrary geodesic
plane and h3 I should be careful I can't
make it as close as I want in the
hyperbolic metric to it a geodesic plane
because this is going to be kind of
quasi geodesic it'll be give us a quazy
fuchs in subgroup but if I just think of
the hyperbolic space if I use the model
of the plonker a ball or it's sitting
inside are three and I take the ax
clitty in metric in r3 then I can make
the lift of the immersion the image of
the lift of the immersed surface be as
close as I want in this Euclidean metric
on our three right that makes this
hyperbolic space compact or its closure
compact I can make it as close as I
on in our 32 an arbitrary g tessic plane
in three-dimensional hyperbolic space
okay and that's what i mean by service
subgroups are everywhere and in
particular if I took a sort of tangent
plane in the three manifold I could make
my surface sort of go through that okay
so let me take that more precisely this
way no oh just I have to do it this way
of course okay so let me just do it this
way so let so if m is a close hyperbolic
three manifold if I take a circle in the
boundary of the three manifold and I
have some tolerance Delta then there's a
closed hyperbolic surface s and adults a
nearly isometric and GD sick immersion f
from s2m that lifts to the universal
cover and then extends to the boundary
and the mere fact that it extends
continuously to a boundary implies that
this map is injective on fundamental
group so it lifts to the universal cover
and extends to the boundary such that
this image on the boundary I'm just
looking at now what goes on in the
boundary where we again naturally have
say Euclidean metric or a visual metric
this image on the boundary is as close
as we want to our circle our kind of
round circle on our given round circle
on the boundary of the universal cover
of em okay so this theorem of course is
due to the speaker and Vladimir
Markovich and that's our contribution to
a virtual hakan man okay so I've given
many lectures on the proof of this
theorem and as I said today I'm a bird
not a frog so I'm going to give a very
wide survey of theorems leading to the
virtual hakan theorem rather than
proving again this theorem okay so what
this theorem implies by the work of
burger on and weiss after Sagay of
is that we start with so we can think of
our manifold as being a quotient of a
group acting isometrically on
three-dimensional hyperbolic space and
what this theorem applies is that we can
also get a we can make a cube complex so
this is a genuine four-dimensional
hypercube here if you look very
carefully so this cube complex it's this
thing you make out of cubes by
assembling them together on their faces
the dimensions of the cubes could be
greater than three okay so it's not
anything like a homeomorphism but we get
a cube complex and we get an action of
the same fundamental group of the
manifold on the cube complex okay and
such that the quotient here will be
compact so we can get the fundamental
group of the manifold to act on this
cube complex and this cube complex up
here will be simply connected I should
put that somewhere so X here so should
say a word about terminology here so
this cube complex will be simply
connected and non positively curved and
the quotient will not be simply
connected but it will be compact and
also non positively curved so in a
moment I'll define a sort of local and
combinatorial notion of non positive
curvature after Grove but one way of
saying it is just that this simply
connected cube complex X tilled is cat 0
and that just means that it has a
comparison condition with Euclidean
space that it's kind of more at least as
negatively curved so to speak the
triangles sort of bow inward at least as
much as you clitty in triangles and that
implies many things that implies that
this is simply connected and it also
implies that the hyper planes which I'll
define in a moment of the cube complex
are embedded okay but for the moment
we'll just say that it foul
lowes from my work with Vladimir
markovich that the fundamental group of
our three manifold acts properly in co
compactly on this cat zero or non
positively curved and simply connected
cube complex okay so let me talk for a
moment about non positive curvature so
if I have a vertex here in a cube
complex I could define its link that's
just kind of picture of what's nearby it
and what we want to say it's rude to be
non positively curved what we want is
that the links are flags which means
that whenever you see a triangle
whenever you see the boundary of a
triangle you fill in the triangle and
likewise if you have all the faces of a
tetrahedron then you fill in that
tetrahedron and another way of saying it
which i think is actually more
economical is wherever you see the
corner of a cube wherever you see all
the faces of a cube like in the corner
then you have to fill in the whole cube
so if i see this corner of a 3 cube well
if you take like sort of the boundary of
a cube that's like a 2 sphere and that
has positive curvature so that's no good
the only way we can deal with it is we
fill in the whole cube and then we're
all right okay so that's the definition
of non positive curvature whenever you
see the corner of a three-dimensional
cube or higher dimensional you have to
fill in the whole cube okay and again
let me say a word in this overview of
the construction of burger on and wise
following so gave so i should say what's
happening is that we're starting with
this close hyperbolic three manifold and
we're getting these immersed surfaces
that are like nearly everywhere nearly
geodesic and nearly everywhere and then
we're lifting them up to the universal
cover of the three manifold which is
just three dimensional hyperbolic space
and as a result we have these kind of
embedded actually nearly geodesic
services that are nearly everywhere and
we're going to think of those as walls
they're kind of dividers
of the hyperbolic space you know
three-dimensional hyperbolic space and
then the idea is to take code of the
combinatorics of this division and turn
it into a cube complex so the idea is
that the vertices of the cube complex
are going to correspond to normal
orientations of the walls so it's like
if I take a point in hyperbolic space
and I have all of these walls then I
could say which side of each of these
walls the point is on okay so I have a
normal orientation of each wall that's a
point in like a you know plus or minus 1
to the space of walls okay so it's a
point in a kind of huge cube of like to
to this infinite space of walls and so
my cube complex well I get normal
orientations coming from actual points
in three dimensional space but I want to
look at a broader class of normal
orientations of walls they're not
required to consistently point toward a
single point the only rules is that
first of all if I have two walls that
are disjoint their normal orientation
should not be obviously inconsistent
right so I can't have if i have two
walls I don't want to have normal
orientations that have no point in
common okay I could have three walls
with normal orientations that have no
point in common but for any two walls I
want their normal orientations to be
consistent like not like that and then
secondly I don't want to have a kind of
sequence of walls that point all sort of
point on the boundary okay so up to a
kind of finite error the normal
orientation should point toward an
actual point in the three manifold okay
and that describes my possible normal
orientations which are the vertices of
the cube complex this sort of burger it
also gave cube complex so let me say
that in words this is a gay of cube
complex each vertex of this cube complex
is a choice of normal orientation
for each wall and no two walls can have
contradictory normal orientations with
no point in common almost all walls all
but finitely many must point toward some
point in s filled and if there's some
point they almost all point sword than
if you choose any point then almost all
of them points or at that point and we
inductively define what we said what the
vertices are the K cubed are just the
subsets of this kind of infinite cube
complex who infinite dimensional cube
complex the K cubes are just the subsets
for which all of the faces lie in our
cube complex so we have a kind of
inductive definition the one cubes just
require the vertices are in there and
then two cubes we get you know when all
the sides are and what this turns out to
mean is that whenever you have a kind of
cleek of walls that pairwise intersect
then you get a cube corresponding to
this clique of walls okay so that's the
Sagay of cube complex and then right and
then here just to repeat what I said
before given our three manifold we let
our set of walls this is a very general
construction this here is a very general
construction whenever I have a
collection of walls like in a set
practically and or you know some
reasonable space and here in particular
given our three manifold we let our set
of walls be the lifts of a collect of
collection of immerse nearly geodesic
surfaces we just want to take finitely
many of these but we take enough of them
that we can separate any two points on
the boundary of the hyperbolic space and
then Bergeron and wise prove that given
that we have enough of these walls as I
described and they did it in the general
like sort of gromov hyperbolic setting
they proved that the resulting cube
complex is locally finite so all the
vertices have finite valence and
particular all the cubes are finite
dimensional in fact bounded dimensional
and this tech group or in other words
the you know the covering group acts
properly on this cube complex and has
compact quotient so I let X tilde be the
thing that we had constructed in the
universal cover and then X is this
quotient of this cube complex so X is
this compact non positively curved cube
complex that we formed as the quotient
okay so that's now the waist of the
virtual hakan man we've sort of taken
our three manifold and we've turned it
into a cube complex now when I first
heard about this I was actually fairly
horrified like we have something nice
and beautiful we have like a three
manifold I like manifolds and it's
three-dimensional it seems kind of nice
and then we turn it into this cube
complex and it's bizarre I mean the
dimensions can vary and we have no
control over the dimensions so I was
like why on earth do we want to turn it
into a cube complex but I'm going to try
to explain why we want to do that okay
right so just to recapitulate so if we
have a closed hyperbolic three manifold
then there's this finite and i should
add non positively curved cube complex
that's very important that's home
Autopia equivalent to the manifold and
it's nice to observe that the nearly gd6
surfaces we have in the manifold
correspond to the hyper planes which
I'll define in just a second corresponds
to the hyper planes of the cube complex
so it's a way if you like the cube
complex is a comment very nice
combinatorial way of keeping track of
the intersection pattern of our summer
surfaces like how these services
intersect each other and this already
gives you some idea of why we want to
form this cube complex because we have
an immersed essential surface and what
we want is an embedded essential surface
so the enemy is the way that the surface
is
sexing itself or if you like when you
look in the universal cover it's the way
that these services the lifts intersect
each other so if you want to know your
enemy what you want to do is to build
this combinatorial complex describing
exactly how the surface is going to
intersect itself so what's nice is that
the as i said the services correspond to
the hyper planes of the cube complex
okay so i should say what a hyperplane
is a hyperplane is a very simple concept
if i take this pictures a little bit
misleading so let me just add another
cube here that doesn't no harm so here i
have a 3 cube attached to a couple of
two cubes so a hyperplane is a i take a
midsection like you know in any one of
the axial directions i take a midsection
of the cube and then along all the faces
if anything is attached to a face or
even to like a vertex if anything is
attached to that cube i continue that
midsection going along and another way
of saying it is that it's an equivalence
relation between edges of the cube
complex I look at all the edges the
hypercube crosses and I say two edges
are equivalent if they share a square
right if they're opposite edges of a
square and then I just take equivalence
classes of that equivalence relation so
here I've drawn in red a hyperplane of
this cube complex and of course this
hyperplane doesn't have to go through
every cube in the cube complex and as
this example shows it could sort of come
back around and intersect itself okay so
that's the hyper planes of a cube
complex and now having define
hyperplanes we can define special cube
complexes okay so what's a special cube
complex it's one in which for bad things
do not occur and it's not immediately
obvious that these are bad things
but it's one in which for bad things do
not occur so the first is all of these
bad things have to do with the hyper
planes so the first is we want our hyper
planes to be two-sided like we could
take a mobius strip and turn it into a
cube complex and then you know if you
take the center of a mobius strip then
it has a connected normal bundle right
this normal bundle is one component
rather than two and that would be our
first pathology a one-sided hyperplane
would be our first pathology that makes
it not special and we do not want hyper
planes to cross themselves we want
embedded hyper planes and the third one
is a little strange we can have to hyper
planes cross and they could even cross
in several places but if they cross in
one place okay kind of sharing a square
we don't want them to osculating in the
sense that they're crossing adjacent
edges and we want to assume with these
two edges care of vertex but are not
sides of a square because of their size
of a common square then the hyper planes
are actually crossing in the other place
so what we forbid is that they cross in
one place and just Oscar late in another
place and not only do we forbid self
intersecting hyperplanes we forbid again
self osculating hyper planes like this
okay so a cube complex is special if it
has none of these four pathologies okay
so why do we care about special cube
complexes well there's this thing called
a right-angled art and group so if I
take a finite graph as I've drawn here
for Sigma and we take a loop for every
vertex of the graph and a torus for
every click of the graph okay so a
clique is a set of vertices that are all
connected to each other so here when we
do that we get this cube in which
identify opposite faces and then i get
the square in which i identify opposite
sides so i have a 3 taurus and a to
tourists correspond
to this three click and this to click
and you'll see this whole thing just has
a single vertex it has just one two
three four one cells and then to that
sort of simple picture I've added a
torus for every click and in particular
this three Taurus and this two tours
okay so that's a cube complex and it
turns out to be non positively curved
and special and it's kind of the arc
typical example of a special cube
complex and its fundamental group is
called a right-angled Arden group gamma
sigma and it's again very simple it has
one generator for each vertex and 2
generators commute just when they share
an edge ok so that's generates so the
fundamental group of the cell very
complex for a graph is the associated
right angled ardent group and we'll see
that these are very nice groups to work
with ok and then why are we doing this
well if we have a special cube complex
well if we have even a cube complex with
two sided walls then we can form its
hyperplane griff with a vertex for each
hyperplane and an edge connecting to
hyper planes when they intersect and
then we can form the salvetti complex
for that hyperplane Griff ok and this is
the amazing thing we can map X to its
salvetti complex ok to the associate
itself very complex well every vertex
goes to the single vertex of the
salvetti complex if you have an edge you
see which hyper planet crosses and you
go to the Associated loop for that
vertex of the hyperplane Griff and then
if you think about it for a moment if
you have any higher dimensional cube
that means you have a clique of crossing
hyper planes so that you get an
Associated Taurus for the salvetti
complex so you can always map x2 itself
any comp
X and it turns out for X to be special
exactly means that this map from X to
the cell very complex is a local
isometry that's the motivation for the
peculiar definition of being special and
that in turn implies that the
fundamental group of X injects into the
fundamental group of the cell very
complex okay of the right angle
fundamental group of the cell very
complex which is a right angle darden
group so what you get is a subgroup and
we'll see in a moment a quazy convex
subgroup of a right angle darden group
okay so let's go ahead so let me just
talk for a moment so I'm not even going
to define Kwazii convex subgroup but you
can sort of picture it it means a
subgroup and you look at the the Cayley
graph and you have the word metric and
it should be Kwazii convex in that
Cayley Griff and so it's kind of nearly
convex in a suitable sense so it turns
out every Kwazii convex subgroup of a
right angle arden group is the
intersection of finite index subgroups
which is a very nice property it's
called subgroup separuh bility and so we
summarize that by saying every right
angle or group is Q surf which means
exactly this and if we have a special
cube complex not only is it is its
fundamental group a subgroup of the
right angle Orton group it's a quasi
convex subgroup and this implies that
the fundamental group of our special
cube complex is also q surf so it means
that every Kwazii convex subgroup is an
intersection of finite index of groups
it stands for quasi convex extended
residually finite okay residually finite
means that the trivial subgroup is the
intersection of finite index subgroups
extended residually finite bizarrely
means like a general subgroup is an
intersection of finite index subgroups
and we specialize to the closet convex
subgroups and I'll just mention in
passing conversely every Kwazii convex
subgroup of a right-angled ardent group
is the fundamental group of a special
cube conflict so it does appear from
this construction so we've chosen kind
of exactly well again this is due to
Hagen and wise they chose kind of the
exact right definition of special which
is maybe not quite exactly what i wrote
but very very close ok and let me just
say a word about why right angled art
and groups have this subgroup separuh
bility property why their cue surf and
it's kind of the motivation for studying
right angled Orton groups so it goes
back to a theorem of Peter Scott and
when she proved basically that if you
take a surface group like a hyperbolic
surface group that it is that in fact
any fundamentally generated sub group
which i think is automatically Kwazii
convex is the intersection of finite
index subgroups so let's see what he did
so the best example is if I take a right
angled hyperbolic Pentagon ok so I can
have a group generated by reflections on
these sides and these reflections
adjacent sides will commute just like in
a right angle ardent group but of course
these reflections are involutions so
this is known as a right angled coxeter
groups I associated to the right angle
art and group and let's say we have a
finitely generated subgroup of the group
generated by these reflections in the
right angle Pentagon then we can lift to
the cover of this finitely generated
subgroup ok and that will be a
topologically nice thing it'll be kind
of convex compact so it you know it's
sort of deformation retracts to a kind
of compact core and then you can exhaust
it by convex sub regions that are tiled
by these Pentagon's ok and for any such
finite convex you know compact convex
tiled sup region you can take the
reflections kind of everywhere that you
see it and that'll get you a subgroup
basically of your original group that's
the idea you know in a heartbeat
so that'll give you and that will in
fact give you a finite index subgroup
okay because the index is kind of
basically the area of this region so you
got a collection of finite index sub
groups whose intersection is are
finitely generated suffer because you
take a sort of exhaustion of the cover
by these we could take right angle
hexagons or right angle to anything a
hyperbolic it's the simplest right right
angled hyperbolic polygon that's all
okay so that's just a very brief idea of
why right angle art and groups are q
surf alright so and it turns out they're
better than Q surf right angle artin
groups are reefers this terminology was
invented by an angle I don't know if you
call it reefers but it stands for
rationally oh good residually finite
rationally solvable I'm not going to
write down a definition but it's kind of
similar in principle to being like you
surf or whatever and and this property
is inherited by Kwazii conformal by
Kwazii convex subgroups so therefore
there's this theorem of and and then
there's this theorem of Eagle not
therefore but there is this theorem of
Eagle that if the fundamental group of a
three manifold is Reapers then we win we
get everything we want then the manifold
is virtually fibered over the circle so
so i guess the corollary is that if i
should write here at corollary right is
that pie one of em virtually special
cumulated implies m virtually fibered
that's why i write everything out in
advance
okay so so where we are so far so we're
running out of time let em be a closed
hyperbolic three manifold then what we
know is that it has the homotopy type of
a non positively curved cube complex X
and if X is virtually special then M is
virtually hakan and virtually fibered
and pi one of em is Q surf okay and in
fact pi one of em if you take any
finitely generated subgroup it will be
intersection of finite index subgroups
there's some kind of separate reason why
that's true so what we really want is to
say that our cube complex X that we got
is virtually special yeah if X is I
guess in this case well it's two things
so there's a much simpler way to prove
that it's virtually hakan which is that
if it's virtually special you have this
cube complex and you can find this
planet cover where the hyper planes are
embedded but the hyper planes correspond
to the immerse nearly geodesic services
so then they're embedded like any one of
them will be embedded sorry then you
need the agel yeah oh oh so you don't
need the agel yes in order to prove
virtually Hawkin yes you well if you
have virtually special then it follows
kind of automatically okay so getting
cleared of close to it was this theorem
of wise if g is word hyperbolic and it's
so if it's a word hyperbolic group with
a quazy convex hierarchy which I'll
define a second then G is virtually
special and cumulated and then a
corollary is that if m3 is closed
hyperbolic and virtually hakan then what
then mm is virtually fiber
okay so the point is that this quazy
convex hierarchy if you have a hawk in 3
manifold if you can cut once you can
keep cutting and it implies that the
fundamental group has a quazy convex
hierarchy so let me this talk has to
accelerate slightly let me quickly
define Kwazii convex hierarchy it just
means you can take the group and kind of
split it as a free product up with
amalgamation into two groups along some
Kwazii isometrically embedded group and
each of those two groups should in turn
have a closet convex hierarchy of then
one lower haight so you just want to be
able to do this to sort of finitely many
steps to get down to basically nothing
okay like trivial groups okay so that
was a theorem of Danny wise and so that
implied that virtually hakan implied
virtually fibered and then the sort of
culmination of this the head a virtual
hakan man was the theorem of eagle and
it's a very general theorem about cube
complexes we just need to assume that
the fundamental group of X is word
hyperbolic that's the only thing I
haven't defined it just says that in the
Cayley graph you have these thin
triangles one side of a triangle comes
close to the other sides and of course
that follows when you've constructed
your cube complex to be the homotopy
type of a hyperbolic three manifold so
if you have a finite cube complex with
word hyperbolic fundamental group then
it's virtually special and this theorem
relies on this work of Daniel wise which
I just referred to and in particular it
relies on his mal normal special
quotient theorem which just says that if
you have a special group and you
quotient by a sort of mal normal
collection of subgroups it says roughly
if you have a special group and your
quotient by a mal normal collection of
subgroups you get something that's
cumulated and also special or virtually
special okay so in the remaining seven
minutes I want to give some idea of
how a goal proved this theorem because
it's really a beautiful idea and it's
actually surprisingly Elementary so
we'll see how far we can get in the
remaining seven minutes okay so first a
will use this week separate e theorem
this is in the appendix to angles
virtual hakan paper so it says if you
have a word hyperbolic group and a quazy
convex and virtually special subgroup
then you can sort of so to separate the
group is the same as we call it like
agree if a group is an intersection of
finite index subgroups right what it
means is that you can find a
homomorphism that kills the group and
does not kill a given element outside
the group and here so it's this home
what you phone a homomorphism to a
finite group that separates the group
from an element outside of it and hear
what we can do is if we have an element
outside the subgroup we can find a
homomorphism to some hyperbolic group
that nearly killed sort of virtually
kills our original group so that its
image is finite and that separates our
elements from our original group and
what's made italy important here is that
we start with word hyperbolic and we end
with word hyperbolic okay that's the
essential role in a sense played by
world hyperbolic so we can kind of
continue to do this in a way and what I
want to emphasize is that sort of
removing self intersections they have a
hyperplane or a surface it's very much
this property of separating a subgroup
from an element not in that subgroup
okay because if we have an element's
kind of if it's so if this surface comes
around or this hyperplane comes around
intersect itself what's happening is
that you have an elements of the
fundamental group we're tracing the path
in this hyperplane of the self
intersection but that's not in the
subgroup
for that hyperplane right because we're
not actually coming back to the same
place on the hyperplane and when we find
a finite cover where this hyperplane say
lifts where we've removed the self
intersection it's exactly this kind of
separation or if we can find a finite
cover where we well yeah if we can find
a finite cover where a finite index
subgroup that that this that includes
the hyperplane or kind of virtually
includes the hyperplane subgroup that
does not include the given element that
means we found a finite cover where
we've removed this self intersection
okay so it makes sense well okay so
we're going to use this week separuh
bility property so here in one page in
one page is an outline so to prove that
if we have a word hyperbolic cube
complex is virtually special so this is
a Eagles theorem and I've summarized it
for you in one page never-before-seen
okay so our first step is by this week
separuh bility theorem we want to form
an infinite normal cover of our given
cube complex and we want this infinite
normal cover to have embedded complex
compact hyper planes okay and that's the
idea is that as I said this week separuh
bility like separuh bility is what you
use to remove self intersections and
because we only have weak separuh bility
if we could map to finite sub group to
remove to separate an element then we
would have a finite cover but because
we're mapping to some infinite group we
get an infinite cover but it's an
infinite normal cover and the the fact
that we're sort of virtually killing
these groups means that our hyper planes
are still lift to be compact and we've
removed all self intersections so we get
an infinite normal cover with embedded
compact hyper planes and now it starts
to get weird see
if we had a if we were able to color
these hyper planes so that know if we're
so remember we have this hyperplane
graph right where the vertices of the
hyper planes and we connect two vertices
if the hyper planes intersect right and
what we want to do is to find a co
compact action on this normal cover so i
sort of finite index subgroup of the
deck transformations where a hyperplane
does not move to anything that
intersects that hyper plane right so if
we had a coloring of the hyperplane
graph that was invariant under a finite
index subgroup of the deck group of X
hat over X we could take the quotient by
that finite index subgroup and we would
have a finite cover with embedded hyper
planes so it's natural to look at
colorings of this hyperplane graph and
what we do and this is the sort of
surprising step we find a measure on the
space of colorings of the hyperplane
graph like colorings L colorings for
some particular L we find a measure on
the space of colorings that's invariant
under the deck group of the normal cover
ok and then it gets even weirder so the
idea is maybe I'll skip to four and then
come back to three the idea is we're
going to cut this normal cover along all
these hyper planes and then we want to
reassemble it like take sort of finitely
many of these pieces and reassemble it
so that we have an embedded hyperplane
so we want to kind of take a coloring we
want to imagine if we had a coloring of
all of our hyperplanes we would start to
reassemble the pieces along the common
colors but these pieces once you start
to reassemble them into large blocks
they have like stuff inside right or we
fell our faces that are now larger and
we want these faces to be kind of a
single color so that we can kind of
consistently reassemble
in order to make our compact object that
has some kind of nice color property so
we have a measure on colorings we want
to use it to induce a measure on super
colorings of our cube complex and hence
on super colored polyhedra that we got
by cutting along the hyper planes and
I'm running very low on time but let me
go ahead I just have a few more slides
we take numbers of super colored
polyhedra given by a rational
realization of this measure which a
priori is irrational and we glue them in
reverse order of color so the colors are
just numbers one through L and we glue
them in reverse order of color along
faces of the same super color it's a
very good question and I probably will
not have time to answer but the the
brief answer is that when we want to
glue we get certain gluing equations and
the gluing equations are linear
equations with integer coefficients and
linear equations and inequalities with
integer coefficients and the idea is
that if you have any real solution to a
system of linear inequalities and
equations with integer coefficients you
have a rational solution and that's what
i mean by the rational realization ok so
having done all of this what we do is we
get a hyperplane than every hyper plane
that was colored the color one in our
final glued space will be embedded and
what's more so we already have embedded
hyper planes which gives us virtual
hakan what's more this thing we've
gotten is going to have a quazy convex
hierarchy exactly coming from the sort
of order of the colorings so by wises
theorem it will be virtually special ok
so that's the whole idea let me just say
one or two more words about it because
I've prepared the slide so if you'll be
patient there's a theorem of an eagle
that's essential to the second step it's
a completely general theorem if I have a
bounded valence graph then there
a kind of natural measure on colorings
and this measure on colorings is
invariant for the whole automorphism
group of the graph okay so if you have a
group acting on the graph then that
action preserves the measure on coloring
so what I think should be the very last
slide let me describe okay this is a
kind of reworking of eagles construction
let me describe how you get a natural
random coloring of an arbitrary bounded
valence graph okay so this is my very
last slide take a random total ordering
of the vertices of the graph okay think
about that for a moment for example give
each vertex a real number between zero
and one at random and use that to
totally order but there's a very natural
there's a kind of an ich natural way of
taking a random total ordering of the
vertices and then just give each vertex
of the graph the least color think of
the colors as natural numbers give each
vertex the least color that you do not
give to any neighbor of the vertex
that's greater than that given vertex in
the natural ordering but in the in the
randomly chosen ordering ok you take the
least color that has not been assigned
to any greater valued neighbor and the
amazing thing is that almost surely for
almost every random total ordering there
is a unique way of doing this ok there's
a unique coloring with this property and
so this gives us a way a natural way of
getting a random color of the graph and
what's beautiful is and there's no time
to say it but you can actually implement
this ok because if you want to compute
the coloring of some finite sub graph
you can compute it in expected in finite
expected time so it's some very
computable way some very natural and
computable way of getting a random
coloring of graph and it's an essential
step of IANS um
virtual special theorem which is the
head of the virtual hakan man so thank
you very much for your time